a la izquierda tenemos la estructura de
puntos del metano que como vimos en uno
de estos vídeos es un carbono híbrido
sp3 y eso lo que significa es que esta
molécula de metano tiene una estructura
te trae drica ahora es muy difícil
tratar de ver un tetraedro en una
estructura de puntos de louis por lo que
traje este dibujo por aquí este dibujo
tridimensional en el que se puede ver
más fácilmente la estructura de
tetraedro que tiene el metano si
queremos ver las caras de este tetraedro
pues podemos empezar por unir todos
estos hidrógenos y entonces aquí tenemos
una de las caras del tetraedro para ver
otra de las caras podemos unir estos
tres hidrógenos construyendo la base y
finalmente para terminar de construir el
tetraedro y ver las otras dos caras que
damos tenemos que unir esta arista
y listo ahí está nuestro tetraedro ahora
algo que nos interesa muchísimo es cuál
es el ángulo de enlace y eso es cuál es
este ángulo de aquí
ok entre este hidrógeno este carbono y
este otro hidrógeno y bueno resulta que
ese ángulo es de 109.5 grados ahora este
no es el único ángulo de enlace también
está el ángulo de enlace entre este
hidrógeno este carbono y este otro
hidrógeno o sea este ángulo que también
mide ciento 9.5 grados al igual que este
otro ángulo y el ángulo entre este
hidrógeno al carbono y cada uno de estos
dos hidrógenos todos miden ciento 9.5
grados y a continuación vamos a ver una
demostración de este hecho pero para eso
necesito sacar este otro modelo que se
encuentra por acá una muy forma fácil de
demostrar que el ángulo de enlace de 600
9.5 grados es tomar nuestro tetraedro
un poquito y ponerlo en un eje
cartesiano ok tenemos aquí el eje x
luego por aquí tenemos el elche y el eje
z y aquí en el mero centro en el 0 0 0
colocamos el carbono y entonces lo único
que nos falta es colocar en cuatro
puntos a los cuatro hidrógenos en
realidad podemos poner a esos cuatro
hidrógenos en cualesquiera cuatro puntos
pero tienen que cumplir con dos
condiciones una es que esos cuatro
hidrógenos tienen que estar a la misma
distancia del carbono y la otra
condición es que estos cuatro hidrógenos
tienen que tener la misma distancia
entre ellos si cumplimos esas dos
condiciones ya tenemos un tetraedro
entonces pues vamos a poner aquí unos
puntos que utilizaron mis alumnos en una
de sus tareas decidieron que este
hidrógeno iba a estar en el punto raíz
de 210 y bueno mis alumnos escogieron
este
después de hacer muchas cuentas porque
este punto junto con los otros que voy a
poner hacen que la molécula esté
colocada de una forma muy simétrica y
entonces sea más fácil calcular estos
ángulos de enlace no vamos a hacer todas
las cuentas aquí pero tú podrías
hacerlas en algún otro momento entonces
otro punto este punto de aquí es el
punto menos raíz de 2 10 este otro punto
de aquí es el punto cero menos 1 y la is
de 2
este punto que está como que alejado
hacia el fondo es el punto 0 - 1 - raíz
de 2
si quieres puedes ponerle una pausa y
calcular que todos estos puntos se
encuentran a la misma distancia los unos
de los otros y a la misma distancia del
carbono pero bueno continuamos y lo que
nos interesa es calcular este ángulo de
enlace sin embargo ese ángulo todavía no
lo podemos calcular directamente lo que
sí podemos hacer es calcular este ángulo
de aquí así es que a este ángulo le
vamos a llamar el ángulo theta y resulta
que como la longitud de este lado es
igual a la longitud de este lado y lo
mismo sucede con estos dos lados
entonces este ángulo y este ángulo son
exactamente iguales pero bueno
calculemos el ángulo theta podemos
calcular este ángulo porque este cateto
de este triángulo mide 1 y este cateto
de este triángulo mide raíz de 2 y
entonces sabemos cuál es la tangente del
ángulo theta porque la tangente de un
ángulo es cateto opuesto entre acá
yacente así es que tenemos cateto
opuesto entre cateto adyacente raíz de 2
y ya que tenemos la tangente de un
ángulo que en este caso es uno entre
raíz de dos lo único que tenemos que
hacer es sacar la inversa de la función
tangente que a veces se le llama arco
tangente oa veces simplemente se le pone
el nombre de la función tangente a la
menos uno de la tangente del ángulo que
en este caso es uno entre raíz de dos
sabemos que la inversa de la tangente de
uno entre raíz de dos es el ángulo que
estamos buscando así es que sacamos
nuestra calculadora tenemos el 2 sacamos
la raíz colocamos 1 entre lo que tenemos
y hacemos
y sacamos la tangente inversa y nos
queda 35.27 si redondeamos a los
centésimas
entonces teta es aproximadamente 35.27 s
es este ángulo de aquí y ahora nos
interesa sacar este ángulo de acá por lo
que pensamos en todo este ángulo de aquí
que sabemos que es 180 grados y a todo
ese ángulo le quitamos dos veces el
ángulo de tangente osea ponemos menos 2
x 35.27 y lo que nos queda es
aproximadamente ciento 9.5 grados
entonces el ángulo de enlace entre estos
hidrógenos y el carbono es de 109 punto
5 grados